[Music]
[Applause]
Steve Young the Hall of Famer fritzy
tracked him down fritzy was going to be
mean Joe Greene or Lawrence Taylor he
was going to find Steve Young and Steve
Young the Hall of Famer set to join us
on the program
Steve good morning how are you I don't
know what to tell you brother other than
uh just pure stupidity I owe you but uh
I apologize but I I never want to let
you down that's for sure number One
never let down Dan Patrick so trying to
make up for it here I'll give you the
best I got for the next five minutes
okay well we called Jim druckenmiller
because we couldn't find you I said get
me a Niner quarterback Niner
Garcia
what do you know was busy we're trying
to find a Niner quarterback so yeah
we're okay well it wasn't available what
happened
um are you gonna take your girls to see
the Barbie movie
uh they well one of my youngest wasn't
last night and uh I guess we're all
gonna try to go to Oppenheimer tonight
and then maybe towards the end of the
week so yeah I think it's happening in
our family I got everybody in the
summertime how many when's the last time
you all went to the movies it's been a
while so it's kind of nice to even think
about but when
the first time did we play golf you
didn't have any kids right that's how
long that's yeah we were could I go back
yes but I remember and then you had kids
and then you started asking me about oh
my God you didn't tell me and I go you
didn't ask about kids and especially
girls can I help you with anything now I
have three girls who are 25 and older
yes so teenage girls
um they are uh a festival it's a
festival it's like uh like you know but
I but I love it I I honestly my girls
are my Saving Grace my boys who are
older
um you know we're boys and uh they're
trying to figure it out the girls are on
it and uh and I love it and they and
both of them are tremendous athletes and
so much fun to be around and my my
oldest girl is going to be a senior this
year decided to try high jump and then
went to the state championship in
California and now is getting recruited
it after three weeks of high jump so uh
you know she's having fun and my other
one's a dancer and I
help right now I feel like I got
in they're making up for dads all all
dad's shortcomings okay but don't let
him fool you though when you let your
foot off the accelerator a little bit
they they might take advantage of you
but uh I'm glad I might come back to you
I might come back here
um and then you're doing you're going to
coach flag football yeah well I I uh
John pay who played uh before Jim
drunken Miller was the quarterback of
the 49ers and uh he's been the coach
over at Menlo school for many many years
ago and girls basketball uh which my my
daughter plays uh the school is starting
the whole league is starting a women's
flag football in the fall like it's a
very organized a very big commitment and
so he called me said if you want to come
over and help out a little bit and uh I
I can come over every once in a while
and help out and that's how that that's
all that happened so John pays the coach
and uh and I'm gonna bring Kyle
Shanahan's offense to the whole thing if
you were playing now
and the ability to be able to run would
you run more in today's NFL or pass more
you have to Dan it's the game changed
when they change the rules around how
defensive players can launch their
bodies and once they eliminated that it
opened up all kind of space
um uh I was talking to Doug Peterson the
other day coach of the Jaguars and he's
like there's just so much more space in
the NFL game than it was before and if
you don't innovate and figure out ways
to go take advantage of that space
that's been created especially a
quarterback you will lose and so a game
today is my game and so I wish that I
mean I I was talking to Michael Vick the
other day he's like how much we wish we
could go play today because there's so
much space and you can go fill it up and
as I saw Aaron Rodgers the other day and
said Aaron if you're going to go to the
Super Bowl and I think he agreed that
you're gonna have to get on your horse
you're gonna have to go get those free
yards you're going to have to be in
those big games you're gonna have to go
run for 40 or 50 yards because they're
sitting there you got to go get them and
every big game is dude comes down even
Joe burrow now realizes when he plays
Patrick Mahomes I got to get on the
horse too I'm going to have to go get
those free yards that are out there so
the game has changed it's so much more
fun for quarterbacks especially guys
that can run you're not going to see
quarterbacks like Dan Marino or Peyton
Manning ever again because they can't go
get those yards they're free and you
have to have them so that's why Bryce
young is the number one pick in the NFL
this year because forevermore into the
future unless they change the rules
again you have to be able to go run and
get those yards or you can't you can't
win Super Bowls wait we won't see the
likes of Peyton Manning or Dan Marino at
the position no you can't because
there's too many yards to go get with
your legs that are free that make the
difference in the biggest games in the
playoffs that wasn't the case back in
the day that was wasn't the case before
that the rule changes so it's just it
makes it it makes it I'm not saying it's
impossible it's just going to make the
job so much harder for someone who can't
go get those yards they're free they're
open it's the game is look what the
49ers doing on offense so the I mean the
Dolphins the Chiefs but Andy Reid comes
up with Patrick Mahomes can go 12 of 14
in the first you know into the second
quarter and never throw the ball past
the line of scrimmage it's a college
game because of the space that's been
created and it's just not going to be a
place for guys that can't go get those
free yards of quarterback
what would Michael Vick rush for now
uh we both I mean honestly coming off an
RPO and just watching the safeties have
to commit and the linebackers have to
commit and throw the football and and
with so many threats coming from all
over the place and they can't Patrol
like they used to even talking to Tom
Brady a couple years ago he said Steve
the game's changed so much because they
can't hit me they can't Patrol the
middle of the field like they used to
guys that the flats are always open it's
a fun fun fun can I say it one more time
fun time to play quarterback in the NFL
and I wish you know like I feel like the
game came to me this is my game damn
this is my game and uh and we all I can
do is watch it so well I get nervous
about Josh Allen I've said the last two
years you know can you take on contact
even though as big as he is it's like
Cam Newton he was as big as anybody you
can only take on so many so many of
those hits at that position but then
you've got to be people people always
say you're gonna get hurt you have to be
smart
they asked much of Josh and Josh
is such a
um uh Earnest human being he'll give you
everything he has
um
in in so many ways if you ask too much
he'll give you too much and the bills
need to take a little bit away from they
got to give him some help at running
back they've got to take away so he
doesn't have to be Superman every week
yeah Patrick Holmes is Superman every
week because they don't ask him to be
Superman every week there's a lot of
other things that they can do the Bills
Ask Josh Allen to be Superman every week
and then he tries to give it to him and
it's too much and you can feel it you
can sense it and I would like more
Innovation if you think about the
Innovative offense there's a lot of
coaches that don't understand what I
just explained they're still running
plays from 2016. they don't work they're
not as effective you have to come up
with new plays that are going to take
advantage of these new rules and you see
that with Andy Reid you see that with
Kyle Shannon well what are those what
are those plays in Minnesota you see it
in Philadelphia those are the places
that are happening and there's and other
places they're just not going to win
Super Bowls because they're not doing it
what are those plays that you're talking
about
well it's it's more that's how you
deploy
uh assets and how you can spread you
don't it used to be you spread the game
in the NFL you spread out sideline to
sideline you got smashed now you spread
it out you try to find holes in the and
then attack get the ball out in space
and then you know and and then a lot of
it is you watch the 49ers the offense
it's unique ways to get you know the
ball the players in in unique space look
at Deebo Samuel playing running back you
think oh what's the big deal I used to
do that back in 2000 like no it's you've
got to watch the offenses and how they
defenses can't Patrol like they used to
they don't have this they can't launch
like they used to and so there's just
space out there that you've got to get
the ball moving slip screens quick
screens you know think about all the
ways they get the ball out into space
into people's hands uh like they did you
know like the college game of old is now
the NFL game of today Steve Young the
Hall of Famer joining us on the program
we were talking earlier in the show
about trying to look at defensive backs
now and who is a Hall of Famer what
makes you Hall of Fame worthy at that
position because we're gonna have to
redefine what makes a Hall of Fame
running back if if we even let them in
the Hall of Fame which is kind of
strange to say but as far as defensive
backs
is there a sort of a bar there where you
go you got to have X number of all Pros
or interceptions or yeah probably
winning like I think at the end it's
been hard I mean it's always been for
defensive football players in the Hall
of Fame it's always been hard linebacker
it's an it's subjective he was a great
line oh he was an amazing linebacker
well how are you going to prove that
well he was Defensive Player of the Year
four times well that's one way to do it
yeah all pro is another way to do it you
need you need those things I mean he led
the league in interceptions those are
the kind of things that make a
difference but in the end it's really it
is hard for defensive players to get
into the Hall of Fame because it's it
becomes a subjective there's not as much
easy ways to you know quarterback
there's so many ways to to judge uh
objectively there's but running back you
make a great point about running backs
that there's the eye back is is dead
because you can't play that offense
anymore that offense doesn't get it done
and so anybody anybody says oh you know
I'm going to be a great eye back well go
somewhere else and then go to Canada
well that's out too you're not going to
play that position's gone that's where
he mosterted is the poster boy for what
uh what what needs to be for for the
running back to position today and uh
everyone's looking for them they're
they're all over the place and that's
why the values are down and then the
league obviously messed up the CBA when
they went running backs value comes much
earlier in their career than any other
position they didn't want people to get
the money get rookies get paid in the
first five years they don't get paid
less less when running backs are good
should get paid so they've screwed that
up too but I was wondering
not that the owners are going to act we
ask and go yeah we feel bad for these
running backs but is there a solution
where running backs could they do a
three-year contract at that position so
you're you're at least fair to them of
what you're asking of them but then
there's the Counterpoint of they're not
as valuable to what you're doing as much
as they used to be so what do you do
it's a double rub and it really is a
problem because there's the position
there's a lot of guys that can do it now
they're even look they can line up wide
receivers and run and play running back
and people say no I mean that's just
where the league is that yeah the league
has changed the rules changed it we got
it the new reality and for running backs
it's not easy because the the old the
you know Derrick Henry at lyback is just
it's those days are done Super Bowl days
you could hey look you can you can go
Mall people the bremens have done it for
years you go Mall people with a really
sophisticated running game but it
doesn't win Super Bowls it's not going
to get there anymore Niners okay at
quarterback
I you mean Brock I I think the thing
that you should not do with Brock Purdy
even though he's not the tallest guy the
fastest the strongest all that kind of
thing you should never limit him he's
just he I always say the Star Wars
analogy the force you know like Obi-Wan
Kenobi or Luke Skywalker like
quarterbacking like we talked about Jim
drunkenville are you either have the
force or you don't have the force he has
it so I don't want to limit him but he's
got to get healthy I have no idea about
that arm I mean it's I mean it feels
like it's good getting better but that
injury is super weird and I I put the
torque on the arm with the big heavy
football you know I'm sure he'll come
back and play well but how fast and
don't sleep on Sam darnold uh and don't
sleep on tray let Trey cook too so
they've got guys they got a lot of
potential no question but of all the
places you said damn Steve you can go
you can go back and play Pick anywhere
in the league I would Sprint down to
Santa Clara not even a question not even
close maybe I'd go to Ken you know Andy
Reed in Kansas City and I'd be like
don't those two places I'd Sprint to
immediately because of the Innovation
that they're showing on offense that
make the job for quarterback so much
easier and so much harder for the
defense those guys are the you know the
Innovative Geniuses that are dominating
the league because they understand what
we've been talking about
did you ever secretly hope that Montana
would tweak his ankle or something or
like yeah maybe fall in the shower I had
a great tip uh because I complain about
backing up a Lot bill was probably you
know he said Joe was hurt and then you
can come in and start and Joe came
running out the first day
immediately saying
isn't there a long time
was frustrated and upset and I would I'd
go from Mad to Furious to and I ran into
somebody I really care about and gave me
the greatest tip ever he goes Steve if
you don't like the job you have today
then be the best you've been in the
world has ever seen at that job
if you don't want that job be the best
at it and so I was like you know what
I'm gonna be the greatest backup
quarterback in the history of the game
that's how I my mind went it was the
greatest tip ever because then it left
behind all of that weirdness of
victimization and and uh you know I've
been you know I I'm not getting my child
or just be great at what you're doing
and I think it had a lot to do with when
I did get on the field how it went but
it was strange that it was Joe Montana
telling you to be the best backup
quarterback that you can be it wasn't
Joe that said it but
one thing about one thing about Joe he
was I mean I honestly I could go on and
on about the things that I watched him
do and just go oh that is amazing he was
an amazing amazing football player but
it was always awkward between the two of
us like if I saw Joe today he's in San
Francisco I see him every once in a
while it's always awkward like it's just
it's just like what never argued we
never fought we never had words we never
but it's just we were at for six years
just right in the same space so it was
awesome it was it was it was awkwardly
awesome I'll call it did you sh do you
shake hands with you Sam or is it a hug
when you see oh both both okay there's
no there's no animosity there's none
it's just it was awkward it was hard you
know it's like and I I always and I
would say to him they got the best of
both of us that's what happened yeah
through it all they got the best of both
of us and that I think that was Bill
lost a great genius Bill Wallace I think
that's what he was thinking about which
is uh you know we both want to punch him
if we you know
walls but you know we both were upset
with him at times but uh he was a he was
a genius now before I let you go we have
somebody who works with us Marvin who's
a big 49er fan and uh he screwed up
asking Debo Samuel a question at the
Super Bowl and uh he would like I think
I remember this it was it didn't go
Steve he basically go um you uh um you I
like the Niners um yeah uh so Marvin's
been practicing is he got it written
down I don't know do you have this
question written down for Steve Young I
do okay all right would you like to ask
Steve the question yes I would love to
ask you here's Marvin asking Steve Young
all right besides the Cowboys who's your
biggest rival when you played
uh yeah the Cowboys no I just threw up
in my mouth uh
foreign
the Hall of Fame defensive lineman is on
our team and the next year he's on the
cowboys that worked out great uh I would
say uh it'd have to be the Packers right
because Mike Holmgren you know there's a
quick real quick there there's a story
Mike hongan leaves the 49ers gets a head
coaching job for the Packers and Bill
Walsh had spent the last three years of
his life packaging up everything that he
knew he knew that he was three
generations ahead with the West Coast
offense and how he thought about the the
players as partners you know all of it
of speeches audio based paper-based uh
video based of everything that he knew
and he put it in a box and handed it to
Mike Holmgren and a toolkit said this is
everything I know this is yours now go
and be great and on the way out the door
he says I'll see in the championship
game and your question wow we saw him in
the championship game and we got beat
and I remember asking Brett Favre after
the gambling Brett what was the big
speech Mike gave coach Coleman gave in
the hotel last night he told me the
speech he goes that was he pulled it
right out of the drawer
his bill lost his big game speech but
that's the spirit of Bill you look at
the league today it is everyone is a is
a is a is a descendant of Bill Walsh
Mike Holmgren and Andy Reid and Doug
Peterson and it just goes throughout the
league because of the spirit of
abundance for Bill Walsh so my greatest
uh second greatest uh Nemesis was was
was the great Green Bay Packers I would
say uh great to talk to you again my
best to the family good luck with flag
football and uh I hold no grudges you
know no grudges never showed up like no
no no no never no we're in it is this
forgiveness
yeah it's you and me it's awkwardly
awesome it's you it's awkward yeah
much love to you Dan thank you thank you
very much always great always great one
of my favorite guests Steve Young we'll
take it back Marvin did well
thank you yeah you did well
look at that that people think was still
look at look at the smiles
okay